uh roughly two million people have been
vaccinated so far
david carter thank you we are joined now
by dr ashish yah he is the dean of brown
university school of public health dr ja
good morning
let's start with what carter just said
only 2 million vaccinations so far they
were hoping for 20 million
we've heard experts say if enough
americans are vaccinated we could return
to normal by the summer
does this now throw off that timeline
good morning thanks for having me on i'm
still hopeful about that timeline
but there's no doubt about it that uh
things are going a little bit more
slowly than we want i think we need to
really ramp up the vaccination
get the vaccines out to states but then
also get the vaccines from the states
into people's arms it's going more
slowly than i think any of us would like
let's talk about the oxford university
astrazeneca vaccine
uk media is reporting it could be
approved by this week what do you know
about the data regarding that vaccine
yeah you know the data that's been
released so far suggests that
it's not quite as good as the uh as the
moderna and pfizer vaccines
over the weekend the ceo of astrazeneca
came out and said we have found a magic
formula and now we figure out how to
make it as good
and my critique is well that's great
love that we want more vaccines
can you show us the data please and we
don't know what the new data is that
he's promising
i'm hoping we'll see it this week when
you say not as good what do you mean
well it's just not quite as effective it
seems pretty safe
but it does not appear to be as
effective as the modern advisor vaccines
those are both 95
the data from astrazeneca oxford
suggests it's more of like
70 percent let's talk about the new
mutated coverage strain right
so it's been found in the uk france
spain
even canada do you think it's here in
the u.s already and
are the current vaccines effective
against that strain
yeah two great questions david i do
think it's probably here we don't know
we're not
monitoring for it in the way that the uk
and other countries are so first thing
we have to do is start really looking
to see if that variant is here my hope
is that the
vaccines that we have right now probably
are going to end up being effective
we have no reason to think they're not
but we obviously should verify that and
test that out
when it comes to receiving the vaccines
we know that it will reduce the symptoms
right i had a doctor in california say
once he received it i'm not going to die
from it anymore right i'm not worried
about that but
will it reduce the possible transmission
of it
once you have the vaccine
yeah that's absolutely critical question
my my best guess is it will most of the
data
so far suggests it probably will but the
data's pretty light on this
and again you know we're learning so
much about these vaccines
i expect in the next few weeks we'll
know more but my expectation is that
they will reduce transmission
probably not 100 but they will should
lower it substantially dr zhao what
happens to the global rollout once
astrazeneca's vaccine
is approved will it be more widely
available in countries like
india and other parts of asia
yeah so astrazeneca the reason i've been
paying really close attention to
astrazeneca is
that's the one that the world is sort of
making the bet on india has made
hundreds of millions of doses of this
vaccine
if the uk approves it this week i expect
india to prove it
i expect other countries to approve it
and then i do expect a global
vaccination
campaign really getting going probably
based on this vaccine one of the reasons